We did it right.
We had it with Sam Jackson, right.
As Nick Fury. Right.
That was a top secret shoot.
We had to do that like on a day off.
Sam Jackson came in right up.
So, yeah,
the way it works
is, is Iron Man at the end
just walks into his living room
after the credits
and starts living room and Tony Stark's
living room, and he gets surprised
by Nick Fury being there, inviting him
to join the Avengers initiative.
And that kind of kicks
off the whole sequencing that happens.
And I had him do a take
for me.
I knew it wasn't him. In the movie.
We have that actually.
Oh, you have this.
We have find this. This was never did you
I don't know
if this is this is real, by the way.
This isn't a joke like this.
We really film this just for fun. Yeah.
And now you have it.
We have this,
and so.
And actually, I am Iron Man.
You think you're
the only superhero in the world.
Who the hell are you?
I'd like to talk to you
about a business opportunity.
Who the hell are you?
Nick Fury.
As if gamma accidents, radioactive
bug bites
and assorted mutants weren't enough.
I have to deal with a spoiled brat.
Doesn't play well with others,
and wants to keep all his toys to himself.
Who the hell are you?
Nick Fury, director of SHIELD.
I'm here to talk to you
about the Avenger initiative.
What are we avenging?
Whatever the hell we want.
Welcome back everyone it;s Charlie.
Jon Favreau and Marvel
just released another post credit scene
for the Iron Man movie.
A couple different post-credits scenes.
So we'll break it down because there's
obviously a bunch of big Easter eggs here.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
The reason why
Jon Favreau was talking about this
Iron Man post-credits scene years later,
because it's been a long time
since the movie came out,
since he directed the first couple of Iron
Man movies
is because The Mandalorian Season
three just came out and he's on
Kimmel promoting that.
So that's how they got a hold of this
other clip.
It's the third different Iron Man
Post-Credits scene.
There are three different Post-Credits
scenes.
The version
in the theatrical cut that we all saw.
It doesn't have any F-bombs,
obviously does not mention any mutants,
X-Men characters or Spider-Man.
But as funny as it is to hear Sam Jackson
do a whole bunch of F-bombs, obviously
we're going to see him in secret invasion,
so I'm sure he's going to go on the press
tour and drop F-bombs everywhere.
Obviously, the big takeaway here
are the Spider-Man and X-Men references.
So when he says radioactive bug bites,
that's a reference to Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man's spider
bite. It's Tobey Maguire.
Because of when the movie was filmed,
Iron Man one was filmed in 2007.
It was released in 2008.
That was when they were still planning
on making Spider-Man four
with Tobey Maguire.
Sam Raimi was still developing it.
They hadn't officially recast
with Andrew Garfield yet.
In fact, I just did a video on what
the plot of Spider-Man
four was going to be Tobey
Maguire, Spider-Man four,
because they just announced Tom Holland's
Spider-Man four is going to be
a very different version
of Spider-Man four
because they were so far along
in development
of Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man four.
Some video
material actually leaked out from that
I posted on my channel a while ago,
so I'll link it below in the description
because it is pretty cool
when Nick Fury mentions Assorted mutants,
he's talking about X-Men characters
and remember,
this is 2007, so it means that at the time
Kevin Foggy had planned to include them
in the first Avengers movie in some way.
X-Men and Spider-Man planning
from the very beginning of the MCU
to have much more crossovers
with all of Marvel's characters
in the different studios.
The reason
why that didn't wind up happening
is because when they were filming
this Post-Credits
scene, teasing the first Avengers
crossover, Fox had just released X-Men
The Last Stand, and they were developing
the Wolverine Origins movie,
but it confirms that Kevin Viking,
the Marvel people, when they're developing
Marvel Phase one and figuring out what
that first Avengers movie was going to be,
wanted to get a version of Spider-Man
in at least one of the X-Men,
like Wolverine on the Avengers,
because Wolverine and Spider-Man
have both been Avengers in the past.
An Iron Man eventually made Tom Holland's
Spider-Man an Avenger during Infinity War
and Avenger.
Now, while this was all happening,
they were still developing
the other Marvel Phase one movies
like the first Captain America movie.
Kevin Feige
was also planning on using Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in a cameo scene
during the first Captain America
movie, during the scene
where he saves the Howling Commandos
and the other P.O.W.
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine would have been
one of these other P.O.W.s, mostly
because he fought in World War Two.
He was born in the late 1800s,
so he fought in
pretty much all of Earth's major wars
up to present day.
It would have been a very quick
cameo scene, but Fox said no at the time
because that was happening
a couple of years later
and at that time they were getting ready
to release Wolverine Origin.
So Fox was rolling
big on Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
He was like at the height
of his popularity
and obviously they wound up
having to remove this
Iron Man post-credits
scene for legal reasons,
just because they couldn't clear it
with all of Sony and Fox's and Marvel's
lawyers at the same time, like
imagine getting three different studios,
groups of lawyers to agree
on something that's like an Avengers
level battle all by itself.
But while Hugh Jackman was promoting
the Wolverine movie later,
a little while after this,
he totally Babe Ruth style called
Everyone crossing over in the MCU
during Avengers Secret Wars.
Eventually, he was just a few years
ahead of the curve at the time.
Question Now that I had a Tom
who's from Marvel, who works
with all the other studios, he works with
Sony and Fox, that's his job to liaise.
I said, Man,
can this happen?
And he goes, Look, it's
not going to be easy because you're
working with different studios
and their properties that I believe.
Maybe I'm optimistic.
I understand Marvel, They've got Avengers,
they've got a lot of big things
going on, but at some point I just find it
almost impossible.
It is not a way to bring.
Imagine all the Avengers characters,
you know, Wolverine,
the X-Men characters, Spider-Man,
and somehow get them into it.
But I'm in for it.
I'm totally out for
because I think that would be
really exciting for fans across the board.
During that clip
when he said that he was talking
to his guy, quote unquote, at Marvel,
who worked with all the other studios.
That was actually Kevin five years ago
before he became the Kevin Foggy
that you know today.
Kevin Foggy actually got his start
producing on that first Bryan Singer
X-Men movie.
He also worked on all the Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies himself, too.
Thank you, Kevin. Foggy Love you.
Kevin Foggy Thank you.
MCU There was also a cool deleted scene
of Spider-Man meeting Wolverine
during the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
movies.
Originally, Bryan
Singer filmed a Spider-Man cameo scene
for fun in the first X-Men movie in 2000.
And you take one mark B
mark, how are you?
What?
I am completely 105.
That was long before Tobey
Maguire had been cast as Spider-Man,
and they had to remove it
from the movie, obviously,
because Sony was still working
on its first Spider-Man movie ever.
They had just started talking to Sam
Raimi at the time,
But then after Sony cast Tobey Maguire
and after the first X-Men movie was a hit
years later, based on the popularity
of the Wolverine character
in the popularity of the Spider-Man
character, just in general,
one of the most popular characters from
comics of all time, Sony and Fox Legit
came to an agreement to have a Wolverine
cameo in a Tobey Maguire Spider-Man movie.
He'd meet him on the street
in New York City,
even though it was going to be
a really quick scene.
It was meant to be this huge deal.
But according to Hugh Jackman,
when they were getting ready
to film the scene, they had a problem
with his Wolverine costume
and they had to cancel the cameo.
And that's why we never actually saw it.
So even though all of our attention
now is on the MCU crossovers like Marvel
getting the rights back
to all of its characters
and seeing X-Men, Fantastic Four,
all the Spider-Man crossover
with all the regular MCU characters
going all the way back to the early 2000
is pretty much every different studio
has had some kind of major cross studio
crossover
plan that's usually gotten derailed
for one reason or another.
Thankfully,
that's finally done with one exception.
They're actually new reports that Disney
might wind up selling Hulu to Comcast
in a deal to get the full rights
back to the Hulk movies in Namor movies.
Now they do have the rights
to use the characters,
but they can't release the movies,
their distribution rights that Universal
still holds underneath Comcast.
That's why
we haven't seen a Hulk solo movie
since the first Incredible Hulk movie.
Originally, those Incredible Hulk movies
were intended to be a trilogy of films,
and there's been talk
now of them doing a new World
War Hulk movie
like Marvel's actually developing it.
But the problem right now
is that if they make it, then Universal
has the rights to distribute it
and put it on their streaming service.
And Disney doesn't want that
in, at least up to this point.
They haven't been able to buy back
the rights like Universal
hasn't been willing to sell them back
the rights in.
Apparently the same is true
for the name or a character like that's
why they can't do a name for a solo movie.
But speaking of name, or more recently,
the writer of Avengers five, Qing Dynasty,
actually just said that Namor would be
featured in a big way during the movie.
He's a super powerful mutant, so of course
they'd include him in the movie
if he spotted in the Easter eggs
that I didn't talk about in the video.
Just write them below in the comments
or any questions
about these historical crossovers
that Marvel tried
to pull off back in the day.
Everyone click here for all my Mandalorian
Season three episodes and click here
for that deleted scene of Spider-Man
meeting Wolverine in the X-Men.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.